[Music]
damn bad
you're gonna collapse your lungs this
week we've got hell's party
hey this fight oh and cheesy tea Oh easy
take it away Tiffany took a night today
all right our first story there was this
man in Colorado this home owner [ __ ]
homeowners oh you're gonna you're gonna
hold on all right I talk about a
homeowner so this man yeah he's a Mike
Cox yeah a real for real dude suck my
[ __ ] yep okay so Mike Cox and his wife
they they went out skux
went up to to have some dinner at a
friend's house and then when they got
home they saw about 300 teenagers
[ __ ] up their whole house just
throwing a crazy ass party damn their
liquor they just broke into the house or
was it their son or daughter that's like
house party no there is no mention of
any kids any kids that they have but
they are saying that this home was put
up on the market so like if they're
trying to sell it for like 1.5 million
or something that means it's a mansion
in Colorado
oh hello cheap out there that [ __ ] has
to be huge yeah it's really it's a nice
home how do you get 300 teenagers
together i neva have that many friends
they should be must have been planning
that [ __ ] yeah that means there's drugs
there no I don't think so but apparently
they're saying that because the home was
on the market some team must have came
across it and then just spread the word
to everyone that they're gonna throw a
party there and then they just broke
into the home cuz they thought that it
was gonna be abandoned
or empty at least since it's on the
market I did that before that's some
crazy-ass good timing on the teens if
they thought that it was it was
abandoned because they ended up throwing
a party while they were out for dinner
that's genius chocolate from the
teenagers perspective I think that's
[ __ ] genius cuz 300 kids like you're
gonna overpower whoever owns that home I
don't give a [ __ ] I'll take one person
out eat individually until every single
one of them is [ __ ] dead when you're
a teenager though and you see an adult
come in and you know your problem
everyone scatters like roaches when the
[ __ ] light turns on yeah yeah for
sure cuz if it's like a 1.5 million
dollar home that I earn with my own
money that's like straight like I've
sacrificed for this place Sony bust out
the ninja stars yeah we take each
individual kid put them on the front and
then you took a railroad spike and you
spike the [ __ ] feet to the floor
get the other one spike the other one to
the floor and leave them all in a row
what I would do are find buckets make
cement fill it up and then stick my
hands in the buckets and you make them
all wait while the cement dries buddy
this way that no keep partying keep
party keep going yeah yeah you pull up
the bags going on there just watching
it's crazy
Oh bro you want a shot yeah give me a
shot I'm gonna needed all your violent
attacks - the cement we're [ __ ]
specifically Asian he wanted throw ninja
stars you wanted to use a [ __ ] bro
let's fight you're the best [ __ ]
weapon ever you can hide them in your
wallet you take em out a bunch of razor
blades attached here's what you do you
go to the [ __ ] the drink cuz that's
like spike to the keg and you put X
lakhs in it
you don't get the satisfaction of seeing
the repercussion and then you put
cameras on all of all their shoes
you didn't think it'd do did you can't
use any other bathroom yeah the shell of
your house yeah they're [ __ ] it up
already and then chop off their pinky
toe so they'll never have balance ever
again
oh damn they're athletes too tah-tah
track star not anymore I just get a
bunch of condoms and poke holes all over
it come out with a basket and just hand
it all out to grow out of that
yeah there dump it up your friend with
the STD Mike explaining how when he went
any horrible means were also posting
clips on snapchat of this entire party
and to make matters worse in the like
the recent months and stuff they were
painting rooms putting brand new carpet
fill the home and now they caused tens
of thousands of dollars in damage you
know I think the best thing to do is
just get called a fire department use
their fire hose open up the door and
start spraying all the kids right what
it's worth it to see it so it's like
coming home to this beautiful home with
300 party-hearty teenagers standing on
our furniture throwing beer cans beer
bottles squirt champagne all over our
house teens even posting video of their
out-of-control behavior
[Applause]
the home in Parker Colorado was empty
after somebody noticed an online ad
showing the home up for sale for 1.5
million dollars I wish I could get a
house for 1.5 million dollars like that
right that's like a six million dollar
home here oh you know what the problem
about calling the cops are like the fire
department nobody gets in trouble
everybody just scatters that's why the
cement block Han thing works because you
need to see somebody without their teeth
or you put superglue in all the condoms
too Oh
outside and inside you say free loop
free lube yeah and then you call the STD
convincing free Libya I should I got
free lube for you kids if you want some
Lube yeah and like crazy crazy glue is
crossed out and Lou is written over it
crazily
the more you put the better it is I
would buy crazy loop over a regular
loose yeah I don't need Lube I got a lot
of pretty common oh we're moving on to
the next story sounds funny gross this
fisherman is 28 year old he went fishing
with his buddies and when he cuts this
Dover sole this six inch fish not a
Dover sole that's what they're calling
it do you know what it is in all my
years of being a fishing angler I never
heard of this fish is it a saw Falange
this guy doesn't know about a duel
result yup exactly
it's not a Pacific fish that's why it's
a Dover is it from the Gulf Coast you
can't see that's why we don't have that
fish dams you see how sad he was you see
his face that's a pretty ugly brownie
he caught me he got the fish that looked
like this looks like a flounder or a
halibut to tell her soul so he was
joking on with his friends and he he was
just like playing around and then the
fish wiggled out and actually got caught
in his throat and this fool stop
breathing for three minutes
oh my friends I couldn't get it out they
called the ambulance luckily the
ambulance was like insanely fast they
got there in two minutes
it's a uky neighborhood yeah that
doesn't have in the hood two minutes
with a hmm that's at the pier or like
yeah they were fishing right yeah
they're cops
so they got that you could hold your
breath for more than the minute that's
[ __ ] long he held his breath for like
three minutes
no he just stopped breathing so he
passed out Oh cuz I was just gonna I
pictured him going off for three turns
on the timer yeah how did he know three
minutes
perfect they were friends so they
misread time Wow no I'm just picturing
like he might stop breathing time it
guys well no I probably like you know
you they looked at the time when they
called the police and immediately they
called 9-1-1 the cops showed up the
friends when the when the paramedics got
there the friends were we're doing
performing cpr with the fish in there
yeah because he's like spitting the fish
but what do the fish is fat
no wonder the fish couldn't get out
though they kept on pushing it back in
like the fish perspective we'd like to
hot breath their friend passed out and
then he also had like a stroke oh the
words cut of luck is that no probably
just probably his oxygen being cut or
somehow like his heart stopped
oh man so his friends were performing
CPR and the reason why you need CPR is
because you're pumping blood into your
organs so they don't die even though
you're not breathing at least by
performing CPR well none of us are CPR
certified by the ankles and shake them
dude duh that's what the cartoons do I
was once certified do you remember any
of that I do a little cuz you don't have
to breathe in them right you give them
breath yeah but anyways moving on from
the CPR so then finally when you got to
the hospital they use a laryngoscope to
try to look in and try to get the fish
and so they were able to grab his tail
and it took six times trying to get the
fish out because then let's get wiggling
we're still alive [ __ ] dick isn't
girthy [ __ ] oh these were getting
caught on the way I was like a Barbie
and then the doctor was afraid his
throat apart the doctor was afraid that
if like if the fish wiggled the wrong
way or the tail snapped off like they
would have been like the guy would have
for sure man they should have [ __ ]
shoved it down yeah just having
swallowed all the way drink water we
know we're talking about I bet you was
in the air hole that's why [ __ ] up
just fit of mashed potatoes until the
[ __ ] is this my six inch fish can like
fit down a man's dick in their mouths is
can do damage
but I'm just saying like I'm pretty sure
my friend did that I would just like
after he's a wegg's are you okay he's
like I told you you're not funny man I
bet you this board waiting for somebody
to laugh too but nobody's like Rob
nobody kid no cuz if he died you would
have told a story like that in the
beginning no I wanted to see your
reaction then your honor no we all felt
like my god that's called natural
selection the fish lived and he died
god it's like it goes into the water all
you needed was a pair of scissors you
just cut up the fish all I've decided
throat sashimi that [ __ ] no what about
the guy's throat oh that's for I wasn't
thinking about his throat yes do bit
yeah and all the guts spill out tea in
China that's topped off in our cheese we
top out with cheese it's a cheese iced
tea what kind of cheese though the
cheese [ __ ] depends what is going on
here right now
why can't you ever speak English I just
I just don't ever since you've had the
kid you have disappointed me every
jacott what is going on with you well
what kind of cheese a mother cuz I do
that all the time maybe it's just once
y'all just dumb to my defense he said I
was on point prior to the kid okay no I
believe that like that it makes sense
that when with the baby leaves you may
be just a bunch of shits just sucked out
of you that leaves you a little nice
little girl with in the stomach and he
just went up your brains they went
let's apply that you they need to give
the kid and then it your brain doesn't
have a curse out that child the moment
you speak it's simplified alright oh I
gotta show you what you look what's on
the background you're an employee what I
wanted to say is it's just simply
because I'm not sleeping enough that's
okay that makes sense yeah yeah yeah and
you don't sleep enough I never do so
then it's not them why you blaming your
children is my choice mine is [ __ ] I
have to because I got used to it from
when Isaac ah there you go okay twelve
years ago cheese et it's made by this
place called Haiti and so it's this 21
year old dude it's from Haiti yeah
Caribbean tea so back in 2012 this young
dude he had no experience in tea drinks
but then he just started creating them
he didn't create it he copied someone
else be real whoa Alibaba Chen
well he did say it was kind of inspired
based the whole like the heavy cream
that's topped off in a lot of like
coffees and teas yeah but then this is
different because he imports cheese from
like New Zealand and Australia do they
say what kind of changes no they just
say gooey cheese cuz like ricotta cheese
can be kind of sweets yeah I mean when
I'm thinking about cheese I'm thinking
about the most dank blue cheese with
mould and steak and I'm like how do you
use that bubbly mots dry mods that's
what every Asian person uses for
everything this is what Haiti looks like
because and y'all forget cheesecake too
you know I'm saying there are sweet
cheese
maybe it's like the cheese from a Danish
like a cheese danish like oh yeah yeah
yeah
cream cheese not all cheese or spanked
equally yeah it looks good though are
you saying that the cheese neutralizes
the bitterness of the tea with its
smooth and sweet flavor see that's what
I don't understand because you drink the
the cheese with the tea so you're like
mixing it in your mouth and so
apparently this thing is so insanely
popular that people wait up to six hours
here's a thing like with teas with
coffee and things like that they're
supposed to be bitter
that's what's enjoyable about it right
but then now a lot of people actually
enjoy it not tasting like what it is I
mean that's not let me get a steak that
tastes like candy hasn't it been like
that in Asia for a minute but people
will order a good steak and cover in
sauce you know I'm saying like not
everybody appreciates how something is
supposed to taste kill me I'm just kind
of a connoisseur snobby I think it's
even the balance because even with the
steak its fatty right so that's why you
put the pepper on there to kind of cut
through the fattiness so I think it's
like people like things and balance so
and when it is bitter they like that
cream that's true because I'm drinking
this thing it's a Vietnamese iced coffee
and I'm sure it's the sweetest [ __ ] it's
super sweet but it's also bitter so
bitter that it's like is this alcohol
yeah there's a sharpie [ __ ] to do yeah
people even pay other people to stand in
line for that
what [ __ ] and just a few months ago is
when this tea I bet you it's bond oh I
want to try it you only had like a tiny
little shop and then in a few months he
expanded to over 50 locations all
throughout China he's a [ __ ] business
man he said that he gotten a lot of
inspiration from Starbucks based on
their branding and their mark we know
what inspiration means yeah in Chinese
in Chinese a lot of people in China
they're actually straight up copying
what he's doing calling it high tea or
like other variations of what this is
don't take the same yeah it doesn't so
then people still go to hey that's like
what people do like charcoal ice-cream
and they try to copy you guys yeah did
you guys try to copy someone I did not
oh speaking of sweet cheese though I was
just at a cheese event and I had
cheese ice cream it was like it was a
cheddar based ice cream was it good oh
yeah it was tasty actually you know what
kind of salty sweet if you like salty
would you sleep yeah I like salted
caramel stuff yeah yeah then you would
[ __ ] with it hope you guys enjoyed that
episode of JK news make sure to stay
connected because we're constantly
updating our social media so follow us
at JK films for Instagram and at JK
films for Twitter to watch more videos
click right over here
[Music]
you